[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter
theory in this video we're going to be
discussing fantastic beasts 3
once again this will be the last video
on the topic for a while
but given that the film franchise will
continue after johnny depp's resignation
i thought that it would be interesting
to share with you the perspective of his
co-star
who plays dumbledore jude law dumbledore
and grindelwald are two integral parts
of the film franchise
and given that law's co-star depp is
being ousted it certainly creates a bit
of an interesting dynamic
the two actors play the respective
powerhouse of each faction
in the struggle of good against evil
right versus wrong
in their youth each boy came to the
understanding that certain actions
regardless of their questionable moral
nature could be forgiven
in pursuit of the greater good a slogan
which grindelwald later adopted
under his wizard-centric regime and now
that two out of the five films have
already been made
i'm sure it's going to be a bit of an
odd change for lol we'll now have to act
out the remaining three films
without his former co-star depp was
asked by warner brothers to resign after
losing a libel suit with the sun
newspaper
over allegations that depp is a wife
beater in spite of the court's ruling
fans are certainly rallying in support
of deb and though i don't expect to see
him back in the film
i don't think this is going to be too
much of a hit to his reputation
in a conversation with entertainment
tonight law addresses depp
leaving the film franchise in a
situation like this
you defer to the studio that's all you
can do because you have to turn up and
play your part
in a franchise like this it's the studio
and the company that make the big
decisions
you have to go along with those because
we're just a member of the team
he also added it was unusual for me
because
in fact on this particular role johnny
had actually done days filming
i think on his own like a true
professional law is staying out of the
politics
and doing what he does best acting law
also included that the next installment
of fantastic beasts
would be an enormous film with many
layers to it
which should come as exciting news to
fans particularly those that were
otherwise unimpressed by the film so far
it seems like they're putting a lot of
effort into the film still to come
and it's looking as though mads
mikkelsen will be dep's replacement
that's it for this video stay tuned for
many history of videos on the way
until next time it does not do to dwell
on dreams and forget
to live
you